[Music]
breathe
you dare enter this house oh [ __ ] it's
Monday morning with taken hostages
[ __ ]
how do your nutsack and clean your toes
gonna be a hot one today [ __ ] and
you want to be ready uncle Joey here
Monday July 10th swingin dick and given
our popsicles ready to go you understand
me we had a little calamity last 100
shirt
for the show you two have to start a
deck and he saw all the movies he did
slash before his life it happens
all right be Pauly well every schedule
he didn't even make it to the couch but
he's fine I talked to him this morning
it happens you understand me
that's what happens when you come to the
Buddha lounge hanging up repaired you
better be ready a rock when you come to
the Voodoo Lounge but anyway that's
another story what's happening you bad
[ __ ] I know you're sitting at
going Jesus Christ I don't feel good my
tummy hurts I had too many wings on
Sunday [ __ ] you [ __ ] get out
there somebody is [ __ ] rotten against
you you gotta plot against them it's
your day to go out there and stab
another [ __ ] right to [ __ ] effect
enough is enough enough with dreams
dreams can just get you to the [ __ ]
door you got to kick that [ __ ] fort
down you understand me that's the
problem people I have a dream so this
[ __ ] Mong Luther King you know saying
I really got a [ __ ] dream you got to
kick the [ __ ] and go it down kick down
the door wave in the 4th war but anyway
we got some [ __ ] Skywalker and we got
this [ __ ] put to rout classic old
Jean and it's time to see the double you
understand me I got a meeting tonight at
jujitsu we got a podcast at 8 o'clock
you know me I'm moving like a [ __ ]
shark it's never [ __ ] end you don't
know when we're gonna bite you you just
know that we're [ __ ] they understand
this is the real week - not this other
[ __ ] weed in his color oh my god it
gives me such a body I get the [ __ ]
outta here you with your micro dosing
when you come into the valley of death
when uncle Joey was sparking mother
[ __ ] bowls of death never mind you
with your [ __ ] micro dosing these
[ __ ] California weaklings they get
weaker by the day with new expressions
on marijuana who the [ __ ] let all these
weaklings into the [ __ ] marijuana
business anyway this was a business I
was professional for people wanted to
see the Dublin Joey end up with the
[ __ ] air beat but smoked a bowl I
know I know
let's try this classical egg when did
the Mary and I'm saying all these
liberals got into the medical marijuana
[ __ ] field all of a sudden out of
people and you know I'm micro dose what
the [ __ ] are you talking about I'm
microdot [ __ ] acid the 80s what the
[ __ ] you talking about micro dose get
your [ __ ] together stop hanging out with
this [ __ ] weak [ __ ] Americans at
Starbucks talking about the same [ __ ]
everybody else is talking about make up
your [ __ ] mind did you see the Jimmy
I'm I'm [ __ ] documentary on HBO last
night part 1 part 2 semi part 3 for
[ __ ] watching see what the [ __ ] real
man acting that guy's a [ __ ] Savage
black oh I didn't give a [ __ ] jack
anyway sorry about that this week took
me to a different place
nice now I'm calm down but you get my
[ __ ] point alright you got no time to
[ __ ] around with these little half of
[ __ ] with their stupid [ __ ] and then we
green chata you want to be a [ __ ]
Savage you're gonna hang out with
[ __ ] Sabbath I don't give you got a
foot of boning in those to remind you
every day that you're a [ __ ] Savage
that's it that's it and that's not
enough with the [ __ ] and the stories
and the [ __ ] and well the reason why I
can't do it at the time is because I
have a job say no you're not stop
telling yourself excuses grab your [ __ ]
open up some of these mouths and shoot
your [ __ ] little [ __ ] today's
the day Monday July 10th you know saying
Christmas is six months away and you're
still sitting there [ __ ] ITT Tech ITT
Tech ain't gonna get good job cuts up if
you ever get that job yourself
I'm ready to go I had my little
scrambled egg we'll have my little
protein shake I gotta talk to some
[ __ ] people now with ten and take a
[ __ ] a beatin
but 12 from hold little jujitsu today do
a little riding and then we got the
[ __ ] podcast Mookie that's it
and then this [ __ ] Thursday Friday
Saturday that's right [ __ ] st. louis
MO st. louis MO [ __ ] helium
comedy huh
if you ain't there you ain't [ __ ]
nowhere you understand that even if the
Cardinals are in town who gives a [ __ ]
uncle Joey's in town tonight my niece is
coming I got some nephew showing up I
got Joe if a lot of showing up a guy
keeps Kathy showing up on a North Bergen
you know how we do it all [ __ ] dogs
running I mean the two weeks we got some
[ __ ] Borgata
you understand me July 29 philadelphia
stop [ __ ] around they had a lot of
tickets up don't come crying to me the
night out with y'all we wanted to see
you jump jump [ __ ] let's do another
Modi then come on [ __ ] fire here then
we're ready to go this is it there's
what Monday's are all about getting up a
little early and doing a little writing
I was already on the phone [ __ ]
yelling and screaming the 7:15 this
morning writing in the [ __ ] memoir
you know uncle Joey never [ __ ] stop
moving Jack everybody wants to [ __ ]
go to heaven but nobody wants to die
suck my [ __ ] dick it's kind of
[ __ ] yes [ __ ] or get off the [ __ ]
Park House up is it shall I dent and
you're still telling yourself excuses
there's no time for [ __ ] excuse you
got to grab your ball salute the flag
and go you know what today
somebody's gonna sniff my nutsack
because it's not I'm gonna [ __ ]
but anyway you know I love you
[ __ ] with all my heart I'm here
for you I am at your disposal uncle Joey
savagery not giving a [ __ ] you
understand me you got to put your
blinders on and just make them move
people okay put your head down and go it
all works out at the end and if not
you've got a roast beef sandwich you
pick yourself up you do ten push-ups and
you go back up there and God you
understand you know many times I did
that [ __ ] 22 thousand times including
the prison stint so stop your [ __ ]
excuses it's Monday grab your balls
salute the flag and say somebody's gonna
pay cut me waking up today that's how we
do it at [ __ ] the church or what's
happening now somebody's gotta pay for
me to get up to that if that's not your
motto
shoot yourself in the [ __ ] eyeball
right now you understand me become a
statistic somebody's got to pay for you
to wake up every morning that's how old
who drew think somebody's paying I'm
getting up I'm putting my slippers on
where's the [ __ ] bagel somebody's
paying for this [ __ ] today you
understand me or you Luna that you think
I'm a Michael ah pain go away and that's
it that's the way we do with you eight
o'clock tonight the Church of what's
happening now if not I'll see you
[ __ ] Thursday helium st. Louis
8:00 p.m. be there stars of that bows
and arrows [ __ ] Isis is gonna be
there forget about it
see you [ __ ] tonight eight
o'clock the church and what's happening
now don't be late alright have a great
day you know poor Joey loves you without
you [ __ ] I'd have dick so you
guys are the backbone of the
organization
stay black have a good day and don't
take [ __ ] from nobody
you